CNN is now learning FBI
special agents across the country
are actively looking for
possible domestic terrorist threats
related to Trump's upcoming court.
Appearance in Florida.
Sources say some pro-Trump groups
are already making plans
to travel to Miami
and support
the former president as he faces
these federal charges
in the classified documents case.
CNN's
Josh Campbell is joining us right now.
Josh, I know you've been talking
to your sources in the FBI and elsewhere.
What more are you hearing?
Well, Wolf, this is so important
because we know that
Donald Trump's
election lies inspired
that deadly January six insurrection
at the Capitol
and US federal law
enforcement is working to make sure
that that doesn't happen again.
I spoke to five law enforcement
sources across the country today
who said that
FBI, domestic
terrorism agents and analysts
are actively working to identify
any potential threats
surrounding that cub coming
court appearance.
They are looking at online platforms
that are popular with extremist groups.
This is important.
They are also querying
and tasking
confidential human informants
who report on these domestic
terrorism groups now
as secretive and closed off
as these groups think they are.
They are infiltrated by
informants of the FBI.
That is often led to consternation
among these extremist groups,
as well as infighting and paranoia.
By the way,
I'm told the FBI doesn't mind
that one bed at this point.
There's no indication
of any credible and specific threat.
But FBI agents and intelligence
analysts are certainly looking
for those potential threats.
One source told me that they don't
want to see the same violence
on January six happen
this coming Tuesday Wolf.
Yeah, no one does.
And Josh, I understand
we are learning
new details about the U.S.
Secret Service
and their planned posture next week.
That's right, Wolf.
The U.S.
Secret Service issued a statement
a short time ago
saying that they won't be asking
for any special precautions
to be taken surrounded by Trump's visit
to that courthouse on Tuesday.
But, you know, this is so important.
Their mission is to protect Donald Trump.
And we know that these extremist groups,
they're not going to target
the former president.
They're adherents of his message.
But the question comes down to
what about everyone else?
What about the people
who work in that courthouse?
What about members
of the prosecutorial team
who we know have faced threats?
And so that's why
this work by federal law enforcement
is so important across the country,
trying to determine
are there potential threats
looking online, looking,
you know, talking to sources,
anyone who might have information.
Federal law enforcement
will certainly respect First Amendment
protected activity at the courthouse
if people want to come and protest
and support Donald Trump.
But something they certainly won't
abide in any violence.
So we're told they're working
to try to disrupt, dismantle
any types of groups
who might be planning that Wolf.
Yeah, the last thing we need right now
is another January six type insurrection
over in Miami.
All right.
Aaron, over to you. Absolutely.
Well, the federal indictment of Donald
Trump quotes
several instances
where he spoke in the past
about severe punishments
for anyone who mishandled
classified documents.
They literally go through
and they show them here some
one of the first things we
must do
is to enforce all classification rules
and to enforce all laws
relating to the handling
of classified information.
We also need the best protection
We can have someone in the Oval Office
who doesn't understand
the meaning of the word
confidential or classified.
I'm going to enforce all laws concerning
the protection of classified information
No one will be above the law
I mean, it's actually incredible, right?
I mean, it's actually incredible.
Andrew Kosinski joins me,
senior editor of CNN's K File.
And Andrew,
you have gone through these
you had found all of these instances
and this is something
where Trump has a very long history
of saying
that somebody should be punished
if they mishandle classified documents.
A long history and a consistent history.
Yeah.
It seems almost inconvenient for him now
to have run an entire campaign
in 2016
saying that he was going to lock up
Hillary Clinton for mishandling
classified information in that debate.
He said that she would be in jail
under his administration and his campaign
even sold merchandise.
That was Hillary Clinton in prison themed
in 2016. This is a
remark.
Lock her up that he hammered home
time and time and time again
saying that that mishandling
of classified information
she should be in jail.
Take a listen
to just a few of these instances
that we found
Hillary's private email scandal
which put our classified information
in the reach of our enemies
disqualifies her from the presidency.
She did so knowing full well
it would put American lives at risk
by making classified information
highly vulnerable to foreign hacking.
I mean, she should be going to jail.
I don't know what the hell is going on.
Well, I don't know what's going on.
I mean, it's amazing, right?
Her the classified information
within the reach of her enemies
disqualifies over the presidency.
I mean, there it is.
And your investigation found
that it wasn't just Hillary Clinton,
that there were others
that Trump suggested should be prosecuted
for mishandling classified information.
Right. It's not just Clinton.
Everyone obviously
remembers Clinton
because that was such
a big theme of that campaign.
But in 2017, when he fires James Comey,
he says that Comey was leaking
classified information to the press.
He did an interview
with Time magazine
around that time where he says
classified information.
You go to jail
when you
release stuff like that
and take a look at this tweet
where he talks about Comey
he says he leaked classified information
for which he should be prosecuted.
Now let's fast forward
a few years to 2020.
During that election
John Bolton
was his national security director.
He leaves the administration
under bad terms.
He writes sort of a tell all book.
And Trump is very angry about this.
He says in interviews
that he releases
classified information again,
says he should go to jail for many years.
And then in this tweet,
he says
he must pay a very, very high price
for this.
Talking about Bolton, his book
saying that he released
classified information.
I mean, it is incredible, right?
I think he went to again, and again.
All right, Andrew,
thank you very much
for all that digging and
sharing it with us.